all right Dana really sad day for the
country and so the president looking
very sad and somber at the White House
and now he's got a big rally tonight to
turn out the base for the midterms this
really tough situation for the country
and for the president and both political
parties III know if I thought I saw sad
I saw a conviction and one of the things
he said is my number one responsibility
and priority is the safety of the
American people whether you're
Republican or Democrat that's his number
one priority
I also think that he was like what this
is a big deal and he had just had a
briefing from the US Secret Service
Department of Justice FBI and the
Department of Homeland Security they are
all coordinating with the Alcohol
Tobacco and Firearms and also the NYPD
Washington DC this is something that
they trained for they plan for it is
unfortunate the good news for America is
that the u.s. Secret Service very good
investigators right they have great
leads they have a ability to track the
stuff down plus thankfully because none
of these devices detonated they have the
evidence to be able to look through find
the fingerprint cross-check it with
possibly any social media post I'm not
trying to downplay it it's extremely
serious there could be more out there
but the full weight of the American
justice system and our investigative
capabilities makes it much more likely
that this individual or this group will
be caught sooner than later hopefully as
soon as possible
Greg what do you think about the targets
here all high profile Democrats former
presidents and very harsh critics of
this president just a series of of mail
bombing sense of these individuals does
this make any sense to you you could
draw a number of conclusions you could
say well this is somebody who doesn't
like these people that would be the
obvious thing but I would say that this
is not a normal act so don't act like
it's a normal act by a normal person
triggered by rhetoric it's an act of
terror by likely a deranged perpetrator
or or a group but I'm always when I look
at stuff like that
it looks almost always like it's a
single person but I'm a wait-and-see guy
so I don't want to make I don't I think
in times like this you have you should
have less speculation not more
speculation the problem with cable news
is you required to build time and
speculate but
I realized that when it becomes to mass
shootings and and suspicious packages
and certain events the first conclusion
is often the first conclusion on Twitter
is never the right one the guy that
comes out first usually ends up looking
like an idiot so you need I think less
speculation is better but I wanted to
say that this is illustrating how easy
it is to disrupt a free society simply
with fear and panic one person one
person or a handful of people can have
an impact of millions with boxes pipes
and postage and it's a mitten and I
think the upside to this is that it is
so shocking because it's rare and we
have to remind ourselves it shocks us
because it's rare because back in the
1970s
this wasn't rare this was a common
problem there were there were actual
terror groups domestic terror groups
more than a handful of them who would
who were setting bombs pipe bombs trying
to kill police officers actually blowing
up themselves this was a regular thing
after you know in the early 70s mid 70s
so we're - this is a rare disgusting
event it's an act of terror but to go
and try to speculate on anything without
first having an arrest or a suspect I'd
stay away from it I think recently Trump
family members received white powder in
the mail and then some Trump cabinet
officials Wan received ricin but this
looks like it's taken to a whole nother
level when you look at the the level of
of democratic you know office holders
former presidents former attorney
generals and and George Soros who's you
know very very influential person in the
Democratic Party in terms of fundraising
and things like that what do you make
about today's events well Isis you know
when I was listening to you guys talk
about the rally tonight and how the
president would have to walk a tightrope
what strikes me is that his rhetoric is
quite incendiary at these events and I
don't think that this is representative
of his supporters in any way but I do
think that there are people out there
who hear him very clearly when he says
oh you know those Democrats lock up
Hillary Clinton Barack Obama he's not
really an American and these people want
to do away with ice they don't want
borders these are people who want to
turn America into Venice well I mean the
rhetoric and then of course he's the one
who always says go ahead and punch him
I'll pay your league
Bill's the big problem around here is
that we don't want to hurt anyone
anymore that kind of rhetoric I don't
care if you're a Republican or Democrat
really does invite violence and then you
see this today and of course I think for
people on the left the instinct and it's
a thing it's a mistake would be to jump
and say I know exactly the source of
this the fact you just did no I did just
said it's rhetoric no I said that what
you see at those rallies and I think
that you and Dana both spoke to this at
times he uses fear to stir his base and
you're so you implied that cause this no
I'm implying that that is the
environment Greg that we live in today
in the United States and I think it's
the one that paints our political
opponents as people who are not
americans not patriots not worthy and I
think then it invites the kind of lone
actor or someone who may be deranged to
engage in this very destructive behavior
Emily do you draw a line between the
president's rhetoric and today's events
I do think with all due respect one that
it's a bit irresponsible to directly
make that assumption to make that tie
that that rhetoric causes just recently
we had a Democratic a former Democratic
staffer that was arrested charged with
multiple felonies for daxing three GOP
senators certainly you can't isolate not
only the rhetoric but also the actual
acts and that brings to me to my next
point which is that we shouldn't isolate
this or we should include a larger
spectrum of what this act means and by
that so this was there was an explosive
device there was also powder as you
pointed out that's kind of two different
things
when I got my death threat as a federal
acting director I was able to call an
FBS Federal Protective Service OPD
I mean they were at that guy's doorstep
within 30 minutes and my point is that
the resources there's a whole spectrum
of them dedicated to ensuring that
nothing does fall within the cracks and
that they treat every threat you know
the word credible threat that's a
misnomer every threat is credible
nothing is isolated or ignored because
all it takes is one and that speaks to
the integrity of the Secret Service and
as well as the FBI and the other
agencies yeah the Secret Service did an
excellent job today and continue to do
an excellent job and we're going to be
following the story more breaking news
on the suspicious packages ahead